anyone who actually does want to learn
the information yeah where does it say
that
okay good what we're doing this on my
youtube channel we're releasing started
nourishing my teacher we're releasing a
two series video debunking this claim
Jana's and it should you know burial
they trying to meet guys insist do you
see where scone X is going to be animals
are so one guy Mary in a piano do you
say does that make sense you know your
clarification made 100% sense I'm Joseph
[Music]
[Music]
when this why the definition of a child
okay some say it's regarding the
consensus like if the country number one
number two is that she hasn't reached
the age of puberty she has immense
genocide of menstruation so if a girl at
the age of 12 has reached the age of
puberty honest I demonstrated is she a
child alone I don't know I don't know
truth there you go
so what were trying to say is this the
legal age in this country 16 yeah we we
respect the law of the land we all pay
by the Lord Lancia when I say nothing to
that what we're saying is the legal age
in this country 16 now a girl who has
reached the age of puberty at the age of
12 is an adult this does not mean that
okay miss suppose my daughter reaches
age previously at 12 that means she is
she is menstruating and she's ready to
conceive but that does not mean I'm
gonna say okay darling time to get
married no because she mentally
physically sexually ready and also
another factor is this the legal age
here is 16 wife a girl doesn't ministry
and it's not physically sexually ready
and she's six to 16 the note says she's
allowed to have sex but her body says no
so do you see Islam came not to give it
an age I mean not to give it Oh sixteen
in America is 14 do you know this
there's been two hundred and seven
thousand children being married off in
America in America in the United Arab
Emirates the legal age 18 you go to
China and Japan is 21 so they're all
different Islam says no individually
each individual we don't say
sixteen and then you have girls who are
not rich age of puberty and then already
is a consumer sixteen and they're gonna
be allowed to have sex then already
because it could harm them you get it so
that's why it's lamas said each
individual has to be assessed by a
parents GM Chansey meaning okay she's
tied ministration she's ready to
conceive but I would say look my child
is going to get married because I think
she's still a bit childish yeah
so what that means is the only thing I'm
trying to prove here is that [ __ ] reaches
adulthood when she spots men straights
him right so my point here is this the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him 1400
years ago his enemies that hated his
guts called him everything listen you're
a magician you're a poet not a single
one of them come and said hold on a
second why am I looking for
so the fact that he didn't say that
there's two options even that was the
norms of the society or she was not
really said she was another age that's
the only conclusion do you get it
because if we see something wrong in
today's society we will speak out
against Iraq if we do not speak out
against it that means as a society we do
nothing that is wrong Judy I'm Chauncey
so that's why in the Quran and the
hadith the Prophet tradition Islam
doesn't give it an age meaning each
individual has to be assessed just
protect her for her well-being
I know your point yeah yeah yeah so the
point here is this and even there's a
video going around the apparently I was
saying or I will let a fortunate man
marry my Nana will do such as in all I'm
saying is in the Quran and the Sunna
Islam has come to protect the well-being
of a girl you cannot force her to marry
without her consent
you don't chant say she reaches the age
of puberty
well she starts mincing yeah so 1400
years ago life was totally different you
think it was like this go home a playing
the PlayStation no Tom when you was a
look at the
no but someone like Pope for example the
argument would be that well Mohammed the
people's perfect could be yes yes yes
his action should transcend society no
yes that's one scenes you doesn't so
then why would his actions be betting at
9:00 right nah okay okay good [ __ ] good
questions now is to transcend he would
know none of y'all ready because I'm
okay that's not how it claims that's a
very good that's a very good question
God then know of the future of the room
for that that's a very good question
that you asked there yeah yeah so so if
you just asked a question I put it like
this what what Islam came down it's not
for one time but for all time that's why
Islam is saying you cannot give it an
age no but this is why someone like Pope
wouldn't be saying why is it in the
Quran but bob has no necks to stand on
because when Mary in the Bible the one
he for knows God's mother that gave
birth to God Jesus God's mother Mary
Joseph when he was 19 and she was 12
yeah and even Isaac Marian in the Old
Testament Rebecca Rebecca thank you
that's what you know that's what I said
on the phone if you don't know someone
something or somebody or if you can't
ask if they hear you they can answer
right away so it was Rebecca yeah so
what does that show you he bombs with no
legs to stand on bombs trying to build
something from you your house is
collapsing and Iulia trying to build
something bothers no next angle no no I
think his point sorry it was wrong no no
here in one second I'm saying look let's
go back 1400 years ago the norms of that
society
the life expectancy the way people live
their life is not the same as today
aigo today matures at an age of thirteen
fourteen twelve ten yet we're seeing
when we go back then and even today even
today because we're doing research about
some wonderful Institute series video
about this year girls are reaching in
today's time the age of puberty if I'm
lying here we got a group of sisters
from our team to do research they found
six videos on YouTube of nine-year-old
girl same aside my menses at nine
the question that were asking is this
that's why it's thunking for old
all-time because the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him Mary there are six and
waited for her to be an adult and
menstruate to consummate if if he did no
way three years they would have like
okay
she was already and the Prophet just
raped her
why did you a free here this is really
important because the fact he knew she
was not sexually developed he had to
wait three years in order for her to
become an agile then to consummate so
that means in all ages today as Muslims
we would not marry somebody if they're
not ready but you would marry an idol no
see mr. Pooh mr. point of communities
across ever and a woman who has reached
the age of puberty and nine back then
today that age might be sixteen so what
do we go what's the principle look there
was the principle she has to be mentally
sexually physically ready and they
should not miss the harm factor when we
use this principle but let me make self
three makes sense when I want to marry
somebody for example if the Falcon that
says my daughter likes you okay how was
your daughter she's 16 okay is she
mentally ready and she said she already
is she physically ready and there's a
fun fact element is she
oh no she's not sorry it's time if you
can't marry your daughter get it
together
I agree with your conclusion I don't
know it's just
none of that for example said in I
didn't I haven't read all of across oh
honey here none of that it said in the
cross no no this is look what we go by
is so when we say if that was perhaps
yeah but wouldn't have him say something
if we brought Bob yeah if the prophet
salla sudden came in front of him Bob
will say look if someone doesn't want to
believe they won't believe Bob here is
not here to learn that's why I don't
want to speak to him you I know you're
not here for an agenda you're here
everyone has an agenda for the truth
good when I'm in agenda he's not here
for the truth Jesus says seek the chief
and the truth shall set you free
Bob and his little team over there that
lady screaming there yeah okay
they come here every week you know what
for just that sake stop I swear to God I
have not seen them come here once and
speak to a Hindu or speak to see all
they do is come here every single week
with a new argument I come and see them
what's your argument today what happened
so they're here is they have an agenda
and I know y'all have an agenda but I've
seen the agenda is hate but if I answer
in like this you know what you say I'm
not convinced today I'm not convinced
I'm not gonna waste my time with him I
rather go speak to a tree
I need the tree my you know it does some
benefit if I speak the blah blah blah
and then he's gonna vote with this he's
gonna repeat the same thing next week
the bunk is claimed you come makes me
can repeat the same thing why because he
wants to make us Muslims bad you stopped
on the Robinson drama Robinson has an
agenda
do fata Robinson follow everyone yeah
okay but to Robinson maybe it's time to
follow him yeah I'm talking always
follow the people who disagree with the
world
I'm joking why I'm saying is people have
agendas here is my agenda here is to
make why people look bad Tom you can
talk to me all day why people do charity
I don't care why have you I don't care
if I have an agenda and from hateful I'm
just going to spin my nonsense just
nocturnal Robinson when he saying Ah
this poor on teaches this and when I
went off to me we need him in one of us
why because he's poking money he asked
about money in his pocket so my question
is this to you is that the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him if he was a
pedophile what they call yeah he would
have Mary I shot a six and
say look I don't care the fact that he
will be waited three years is because of
her will Venus Jim Channon say oh yeah
yeah just for anyone who actually does
want to learn the information yeah where
does it say that
okay good what we're doing this on my
youtube channel we're releasing started
nourishing my teacher we're releasing a
two series video debunking this claim
Jana's and it should you know Barry oh
yeah
we buried not literally but
intellectually we're gonna do it we're
gonna bury this argument once and for
all because fifty years ago
shall tell you something he's a
Christian missionary mafia he's a
Christian missionary I want be surprised
if he gets paid their job is to attack
this town okay I'm here to defend my
religion against these kind of lies and
criticism yeah okay
fifty years ago no Christian
missionaries this argument why because
it was the nose of the society because
in the UK was happening do you get it
what they're gonna say because they knew
how can we use his argument against the
Prophet Mohammed because we're doing it
you get it were Marian girls who have
reached the age of puberty have become
adult so that's why they couldn't use it
but now because societal norms have
changed you know friends you know
there's a the episode friends sure you
show the show friends do you know
recently the ad on Netflix and you know
they got massive complaints do you know
why because how old is an efference 20
years about 20 years old yeah when they
put it back on Netflix people stop even
complain its homophobe it is what's the
quote said what's the funny you know use
more for the world the sexist countries
that's when Itoh sexist it's homophobic
so the question asking is why didn't
nobody complained 20 years ago because
fam Buckland it was no problem but now
society has changed so much not within
20 years their complains in everything
this homophobic this is sexist you see
our society is changing that's why we go
by the law of God because if you look at
Nazi Germany in Nazi Germany few is
there killing Jews was okay because that
was a society to lose the junction see
so that's why what we say is you mean we
follow objective morality we do not
follow a law that now they did in in
Denmark or country they want
insisting the trying to meet guys insist
do you see where scorn X is going to be
animals I saw one guy marry in a piano
do you I'm trying to say yeah yeah he
married the piano yeah
I don't know what kind of communication
I'm gonna have yet but the problem here
is this year Society is going on a mad
one next month marina flippin dog
flippin elephant
the question is society's norms are
changing worse say we stop we stick to
the glows of God
yeah to the best urban is of course and
all of the Landis work cuz the northern
land says look fam you can't do for
example
scum you can't pass a traffic light most
Muslims back home would won't stop at
the traffic light
Judy I'm Janice a so that's about is any
question you asked me
no no I just came to you see my you
wanna do yeah does that that make sense
you know make your clarification made
100% sense I'm Joseph that's me